what's Jackson boy I think he's a
typical five-year-old boy that has a
missing limb but I don't think that
stopped them I think it's sort of
accelerated
so you're able to dribble I've seen you
shoot you pass this thing is special how
long did it take you to learn how to do
that you happy to have that tell me why
can I laugh myself he's a five year old
he loves sports how big of a part of his
life is sports for him oh it's a big
part it's been in our family for a
couple of generations now I have a
father who played basketball at st.
Bonaventure if someone said what's your
dad like what would you tell him he
likes basketball and he played at you
man
I played University of Massachusetts I
had a lot of friends in the business so
he's been in tune to it really since he
was 1 or 2 years old he doesn't look at
his special hand as anything other than
what we call it which is the special
hand you ever played someone that you
haven't met and they try and force you
to the right because you're special arm
and you go by them anyway
what does that feel like fine circle cuz
it makes me get better and better he's
left the obviously and he's got a really
nice stroke he really does for a five
year old five year olds can have strokes
pathway home fake rip through jump shot
she's already dribbling with his special
hand better than then I would expect at
this point his ball handling skills are
off the chart we spend a lot of time
most conscious right-hand layup
left-hand layup so yes he's going to
have to be creative but he's working on
the reverse layup
not many five-year-olds can make regular
left he's going to have to get good at
spinning the ball in different
directions to be successful with his
with his strong hand he's just learning
his crossover so for a five-year-old he
is pretty good he holds his own
we're at the anatomy scanning and when
the radiologist left the room she said
I'm gonna have the doctor come in and
when he came back in you know he was
really pushing on my stomach to turn the
baby around and I would think it seemed
like forever he switched it to 3d and
skipped finally said what are you
looking for at that point is it I don't
think your son has his right hand we
both started to cry and I looked over at
the radiologist she was crying and it
was pretty devastating for us I had
never known somebody with a missing limb
at that point you're you're all all of
your expectations of what your child is
going to do are I once a in danger but
you just don't know so you're wondering
what's gonna happen now you know you
think you're gonna have a son and you're
gonna do all the things that I did find
dad when I was growing up baseball and
basketball and anything how is that
gonna happen not without a hand
here at the University of Kentucky
getting ready for practice this morning
for the Florida game
Jackson is excited to meet all his all
his favorite players Tyler Ulis really
cauley-stein tomorrow Anthony he's been
really exciting he's looking for me
Coach Cal he loves Kentucky I mean he's
now since 2 years old been following
Kentucky and obviously Kentucky's been
at the forefront of college basketball
for a long time but especially with John
Calipari being there you know he likes
to follow Big Blue Nation what players
do you want to play like Tyler Ulis and
you Harrison & Harrison Willie
cauley-stein and it karl-anthony towns
let me see their ball let me see oh my
goodness look at this what I'm talking
about let me see it again
see that ball the most important thing
three in a row
I've known Jackson since he was born and
I don't even think Jackson knows that
man I'm a little different I think he
looks at this and he doesn't see it as
something that's gonna hold them back
that's what makes this great I think we
all grow up thinking are they normal am
I is what's going on with me not normal
you know we're all we're perfectly
imperfect we create the best world that
we can from what we're
which is exactly what Jackson does and I
see a lot of mothers to be or dads to be
asking all the same questions that we
did and now we help them just as they
other people who came before us helped
us he's asked you know is my hand gonna
grow and we said no that's that's the
way your special hand was that's way God
made you and that's what you're what you
have and it may have got a little sad
once in a while but he bounces right
back I think he think he looks at what
he has or what he can do versus what he
doesn't have what he can't do
he's had great examples along the way
with our friends in basketball Kevin
Laue he's met played Manhattan now does
it young man Zac Hodgkin's in Florida
and those two examples we show Jackson I
would show him even on the computer at 2
or 3 years old I would show him the Jim
Abbott story he was able to meet Jim
Abbott what he was - I wanted to make
sure from the beginning I was able to
show Jackson those examples of people
with special hands as we call it that do
amazing things